[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
hace 5 años durante el verano de 2015
europa fue testigo de un éxodo masivo
que llegó al continente a enfrentar una
crisis humanitaria y política sin
precedentes más de un millón de
emigrantes llegaron a europa durante ese
año en una carrera por huir de la guerra
y los conflictos sirios afganos e
iraquíes peregrinaron por rutas
peligrosas y muchos murieron en el
camino
miles cruzaron las fronteras y mientras
unos países los acogieron con los brazos
abiertos otros levantaron barreras y
cerraron cruces fronterizos un trágico
naufragio en el mediterráneo' el cuerpo
de un niño en la playa y la indecisión
de los países europeos por no saber qué
hacer con tal llegada de personas
marcaron la crisis de refugiados de 2015
hacia europa recordemos lo que pasó
a comienzos de septiembre del año 2015
una imagen conmocionó al mundo estas
fotografías del pequeño ailán kurdi
llamaron la atención sobre la crisis de
refugiados en europa que para ese año
tuvo su momento más álgido
tanto que la migración de aquella época
fue considerado el mayor éxodo humano
desde la segunda guerra mundial fue un
año marcado por tragedias al menos 3.500
50 personas murieron durante el viaje
muchas vidas terminaron en el mar y
otras en su recorrido por rutas
terrestres clandestinas más del 75% de
los que huían
lo hicieron a causa de la persecución y
los conflictos en siria afganistán o
irak
ante la crisis alemania y austria
abrieron sus fronteras para la recepción
de solicitantes de asilo y estas
imágenes en la principal estación de
trenes de múnich fueron símbolo de la
llamada cultura alemana de bienvenida
tiendas de campaña fueron ubicadas en el
antiguo aeropuerto de berlín e incluso
hubo ferias de empleo para los
refugiados que gracia fue voluntaria en
aquel 2015 recibió a familias completas
y les sirvió comida caliente luego del
largo viaje comencé a trabajar con una
organización que ayudaba a jóvenes
refugiados duró aproximadamente dos años
y medio fue muy intenso creo que me
cambio como persona
para ella así como lo fue para muchos
otros voluntarios era necesario no ser
sólo una espectadora hoy sigue ayudando
a los refugiados e incluso acoge a uno
en su casa lo volvería a hacer no sería
alguien que desde el principio diga que
vamos a triunfar y que todo va a salir
bien porque hay que ser realista pero si
por supuesto que lo volvería a hacer
alemania llamó la atención de los que
buscaban una segunda oportunidad lejos
de la guerra y en 2015 al menos 800
90.000 solicitantes de asilo llegaron al
país
durante este lustro mucho cambio ese
sentimiento solidario que se vio en
algunos lugares del continente se
desdibujó la llegada de masa de personas
desde medio oriente y áfrica y la
inacción por parte de los gobiernos
aviva sentimientos xenófobos entre la
población veamos lo que pasa en lesbos
cinco años después
la llamada isla de la solidaridad ya no
aguanta más les vos uno de los destinos
iniciales para miles de emigrantes que
buscan refugio en europa colapsa
mientras alberga a unos 13.000
solicitantes de asilo
hace 5 años la isla estaba preparada
para acoger a 2700 personas e incluso en
2015 pescadores y voluntarios se dieron
a la tarea de rescatar a los migrantes
que estaban a la deriva tanto así que
fueron nominados al premio nobel de la
paz pero el panorama hoy es otro
la gente está cansado de toda esta
situación las promesas de ayuda y las
medidas hechas por los gobiernos no se
han cumplido sean dime atrás documento
los olivares alrededor del campo oficial
de refugiados ya no están
en cambio los migrantes que no son
aceptados en mor ya han levantado
viviendas improvisadas mientras esperan
respuesta a su situación
los locales dicen vivir las
consecuencias de la ola de refugiados
y publicidad y noticias negativas
continuas con respecto a los migrantes y
refugiados
lo que ha resultado en una fuerte
disminución del turismo en nuestra isla
alegan sentirse solos y creen que el
gobierno nacional no se hace cargo de la
difícil situación en la isla
creo que lo que ha cambiado y lo que ha
pasado es que la tolerancia ha
disminuido porque la isla no siempre se
ha sentido apoyada por el gobierno en
transporte peit del centro gov mente a
kilómetros de allí en berlín con 13.000
sillas vacías ante el race track varias
ong alemanas pidieron el
desmantelamiento de memoria
y es que lo que pasa en lesbos es una
radiografía de buena parte del
sentimiento en europa hacia los
refugiados italia se ha negado a recibir
más migrantes en sus costas y no
permitió el desembarco de organizaciones
de ayuda por el momento turquía sirve de
muro de contención a europa para evitar
el paso de refugiados gracias a un
acuerdo entre los países de la unión
europea y el gobierno de erdogán un
acuerdo que termina este año hungría por
su parte decidió prolongar por seis
meses más el estado de crisis por
inmigración masiva establecido en 2015
pese a que el tránsito por su territorio
es mínimo y por el mar continúa el éxodo
miles naufragan y las organizaciones de
ayuda navegan para socorrer a refugiados
a la deriva que siguen buscando una
nueva oportunidad lejos de sus países
pasado el tiempo los problemas de fondo
que provocan el éxodo hacia europa
siguen vigentes ni siria ni irak ni
afganistán son lugares seguros y los
países africanos se suman a la lista los
conflictos siguen y europa aún no cuenta
con una firme política comunitaria para
responder al fenómeno de la migración en
masa hasta que inmigrantes de france24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
f24 siga conectados con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]